MIHAI IONESCU: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Payments Live.
We have an office-hours-style
session today.
We will have some product
announcements and feature
announcements and, of course,
we will take questions from
Stack Overflow groups
and the moderator.
So let's start with a few
announcements first.
A very exciting one, the new
Merchant Center for Wallet for
digital goods API merchants
is now fully launched.
If you remember, last year we
had the product manager for
the new Merchant Center on the
show and he demoed some of the
new features.
And now it's all reality.
And over the past few months
we migrated everyone.
All new sign ups will now
go directly to the
new Merchant Center.
So I'm going to demo some
of the features.
I'm going to switch to
my screen right now.
And if you see--
the merchant experience is
completely redesigned.
We have a new, modern UI, and,
in particular, you will see
features that apply directly
to your API.
In the past, there was
some confusion--
which features applied to
digital goods merchants, which
applied to check
out merchants.
That is no more the case.
You will only see stuff that
applies directly to you.
Let's start with looking
at the orders page.
So a very straight design, a
more intuitive way to present
the orders.
You can see we have some color
coded way to help you decide
which orders have gone through,
which are still pending.
A very nice feature is
the subscription.
I'm going to show a subscription
order right now.
And, very nicely from this page,
you can now directly
cancel subscription.
It was not possible in the
old Merchant Center.
PENG YING: Very cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: What
else can we show?
PENG YING: I'm glad that we
finally launched this.
It has taken a while.
But we're still steamrolling
along with our products.
So I guess I'll show
off the next
feature, or feature function.
Whatever you call it.
And that's the ability to really
easily specify taxes,
the taxes that you collect when
you sell a digital good.
So what Google previously
allowed, or what Google Wallet
for digital goods previously
allowed was for US Merchants,
instead of specifying your tax
rate or collecting your own
taxes, Google provided a tax
table that you just check box
next to the states that you
collect taxes in, and we would
automatically collect
those taxes for you.
And what we've done is we've
expanded that internationally.
So now we can collect taxes on
your behalf for regions in
Canada, and internationally in
various countries in Europe.
And we understand that sometimes
in Europe it's VAT
versus sales tax.
So that's all handled for
you behind the scenes.
Within your tax tables, just
check the boxes of the
countries that you accept
tax in, or that
you collect tax in.
MIHAI IONESCU: So let's show
something in the [? view ?].
All right.
So in the [? view ?] you can
select the per country tax or
you can select the global tax
for everyone that shows the
per country tax.
So for, let's say, France, you
can specify the taxing here.
It's probably pretty high.
[LAUGHING]
PENG YING: It's probably
something like 17.5% or 20%.
MIHAI IONESCU: You can also go
Canada, by province, and do
something similar.
One nice thing about the US is
that you don't really have to
know the taxes for each city
or for each state.
You can use our own
predetermined Google tax data.
And then those would
be automatically
filled in for you.
PENG YING: Yeah, that's
really handy.
So, basically, on our back end
we have a zip level tax table
that we're using to
collect taxes.
In addition to that, so I think
we recently launched--
well, we recently launched our
business insights page.
MIHAI IONESCU: Oh yeah,
very exciting.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Which is kind of like analytics
on your commerce
sales or commerce business.
We actually brought Mark on, who
was a product manager of
commerce analytics.
The guy will talk about the
products and some more details
about the ways to leverage a
product to kind of enhance
your business.
It's in one of our previous
GDLs, so you can find it on
YouTube if you look
up commerce GDLs.
At a high level, what it
does is it allows you
to get better data.
Well, it provides an easily
viewable version of your data.
Right?
So an easily analyzable
version of your data.
So you can see where your
customers are coming from.
You can see who are your
high spenders.
You can see what regions your
most valuable customers are
accessing your website from.
And then that will help you, in
turn, target your marketing
to kind of improve sales.
MIHAI IONESCU: So I'm
showing here a nice
chart of revenue plots.
And you can also do orders.
You can change the time period
when that is happening.
And, where available,
you can actually get
demographics data.
And this is just a
small set of the
features we plan to add.
Stay tuned.
This is one of the areas where
we have plans for serious
improvements.
And, of course, if there are
any other suggestions or
feedback you have, please
contact us, and let us know.
All right.
Very exciting launch with
the new Merchant Center.
Let's now move on to another
API-related announcement.
This is for the digital
goods API.
We have made some improvements
and optimizations to the way
the JavaScript library
is loaded.
If you remember, in the past, we
were using the google.load
method to load the library.
That was creating some issues.
Depending where you loaded and
how complex your web page was,
it could have changed
a DOM of the page.
And there were some
workarounds.
You could use some call backs
to get around that issue.
But still, it's not ideal
for such a simple API.
We want to make it as simple
as possible to place a
transaction.
So the new recommended way
is through a script tag.
So now everything is
encapsulated in one library
called buy.js.
And you just create a
script tag and put
that library in there.
And everything should
work just fine.
If your page is too complex
and you want to do further
optimizations, like improving
the page load time, you can
create the script tag
dynamically and insert the
library at the moment that is
more convenient in your page
loading or by flow.
Let me switch to our
documentation so I can show
you an example.
So this is our code snippet in
the demo that we recommend
everyone to start
playing with.
It actually looks smaller and
much simpler than before.
As you can see, we just
load the library at
the top of the page.
And then everything works
just as before.
One small change with this new
library loading method.
The signature of the buy method
has slightly changed.
Instead of goog.payments,
that [INAUDIBLE]
buy is now google.payments
[INAUDIBLE]
We recommend that you use
the new signature.
It's also an improvement
and an optimization.
PENG YING: So, do you
know if changes--
if somebody has used the old
method, and then any upcoming
changes will only be under the
google.wallet domain space, or
will it be under both
name spaces?
MIHAI IONESCU: The old method
is still supported.
PENG YING: OK.
MIHAI IONESCU: If you do not
want to change your code, by
all means, if it works well,
you don't have to do it.
We recommend that,
moving forward,
you use the new method.
And, in particular, if you're
loading the library to the
script tag, then you have to use
the new signature for the
buy method.
PENG YING: Cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we updated the
demos to reflect that and
added the required notes
in the documentation.
PENG YING: A really
simple change.
MIHAI IONESCU: It is
really simple.
But it's helpful depending how
complex your page was.
PENG YING: Yeah.
MIHAI IONESCU: And it gives you
more control of loading
the buy flow and optimizing
the experience.
PENG YING: Yeah.
I like that you can--
so I work on some other projects
as well, and I use
defer or require.js, which
allows you to kind of defer
JavaScript loading.
I think that's what Google
load does as well.
But now it allows you to take
more control in when you
actually load that JavaScript.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
It was an extra step.
You had to read the
documentation for google.load
and figure out if you need
extra parameters--
PENG YING: We kind of
just included it.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
Now it's as simple
as possible.
Just include a script, a library
and a script tag.
All right.
Good.
So I think those were the
announcements we had for the
new Merchant Center and the
library optimizations.
So let's move on to
the Q&A section.
PENG YING: Sounds good.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
Let's switch to the questions.
So I'll take the first one.
The question is related to the
digital goods API, the
subscriptions in particular.
And the question is, is it
possible to create a digital
subscription with no
expiration date?
So that is a good question.
And the answer is, yes.
It's possible.
You can create an open-ended
subscription.
And now, with the new Merchant
Center, it's actually even
much easier to cancel
it as well.
That's something that was not
possible in the past from the
merchant side, in an easy way.
So I'd recommend this book in
our documentation for the
subscription, [? Jason ?]
Webtalk on field.
And look there for
nonrecurrences.
That's a field in the JWD.
And note that it's an
optional field.
So that field specifies how many
times the subscription
should recur.
If you leave it blank, if you
don't specify it, then it's an
open-ended subscription with
no expiration date.
So experiment with it a little
bit in the sandbox, and then
deploy it into production.
And you should have an
open-ended subscription.
You can cancel it at any
time or have the
customer cancel it.
PENG YING: Very cool I'll
take the next question.
Wallet for online commerce.
Since merchants don't obtain the
cardholders card data, and
therefore cannot perform risk
analysis, does that mean
merchants are protected
by Google from charge
backs due to fraud?
For example, unauthorized
use of card and similar.
So it depends on what you
mean by card data.
So what you'll get is you'll
get a proxy card, a
one-time-use card, that's an
alias for their back end card.
In addition to that, you'll also
get their billing address
and their shipping address.
So you can still run your
typical AVS and CVV checks
against it.
And those should
still validate.
I think, if your question is, if
you are doing risk analysis
based on a specific credit card
number and seeing if that
credit card number is used by
multiple accounts and that
kind of risk engine analysis,
then I don't
think that's possible.
But you should be reassured that
we're also doing a lot of
risk analysis on our side,
because we do have that card
and we can associate
the accounts.
We can determine the
accounts that are
associated with that card.
So I would say a for most of
the transactions, or a
majority of the transactions,
that they will be secure.
In terms of whether or not
Google is handling charge
backs due to fraud, I will need
to follow up on that one,
because I don't have 100%
accurate information.
But I think we'll leave that
answer for the next GDL.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
I'll take the next.
So it looks like we have
a check out question.
So we already covered
three APIs in
the first three questions.
So the question is, I am a
merchant from the United
Kingdom and I use the
Store Gadget.
I want to add shipping costs,
and I get the following
error-- invalid attribute,
value item weight.
This is not a number.
So it looks from the error that
this is a parsing error.
Probably a typo in your Store
Gadget spreadsheet, because it
says it's not a number.
So I would check the spreadsheet
and make sure that
in the weight field you
only have numbers.
You don't have alphanumeric
characters.
The usual errors I've seen is
people say five pounds instead
of just five or five
kilograms.
So make sure you have nothing
after the number.
That being said, once you fix
that, also make sure that the
weights are actually specified
in pounds.
It's a little bit confusing for
UK merchants, because when
you go into the Merchant Center
and specify your weight
table, the weights are
in kilograms there.
But in the spreadsheet,
you have to
specify them in pounds.
So it's a little bit more work
for the UK merchants.
We realize it's not ideal.
But just to let you know that
there may be more errors down
the road if you don't specify
the weights in pounds in the
spreadsheet.
So I think this will fix it.
Just be careful with the
weight conversion.
PENG YING: Cool.
The next one.
On the roadmap, is there the
ability to assign a nickname
to each of the cards on your
account so they are more
easily distinguishable beyond
just the last four digits of
the card number?
MIHAI IONESCU: It's not
clear in what context.
PENG YING: Yeah.
So it depends on the different
purchase flows, or on the
different flows that you're
entering in the card.
So, Mihai actually showed me
earlier today, in the Google
Wallet application, if you enter
your card in there you
can specify a nickname and that
nickname is displayed
within the Wallet application.
But for the digital purchase
flow, you're only given the
opportunity to enter in the card
number, CVV, expiration
date, and your name.
So in that case, you will be
unable to enter in an alias.
MIHAI IONESCU: So it's
a good point.
Since we're allowing you
to do it in one app,
but not in the other.
Yeah, maybe we should look
at this and fix it.
PENG YING: Well, so if you're
coming from the merchant's
perspective, you want the user
to enter in as little
information as possible for the
highest conversion rate.
But I understand from the user's
perspective it could be
a little bit confusing.
Maybe there's some optimizations
that we could
make there.
I'm not quite sure.
MIHAI IONESCU: I think the
default is the card type and
the last four digits.
So if you have an American
Express it'll be AMX 123, and
you have a Visa, it'll
be VISA 5678.
So it's not that bad unless you
have multiple Visa cards.
PENG YING: Multiple
AMX and VISAs
MIHAI IONESCU: It gets confusing
because you have to
remember the last four digits.
PENG YING: You're just
supporting the economy at that
point, I think.
MIHAI IONESCU: So then we're
happy for you that you have so
many credit cards.
PENG YING: Supporting
the economy.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yep.
Cool.
Let's see.
Let me take the next one.
So this is nice.
We already know [INAUDIBLE]
APIs--
PENG YING: Buy flows, yeah.
A little bit of everything.
Ask more questions, guys.
We're happy to answer any
question that you have.
Or almost any question
that you have.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we have a
question now about check out
integration.
It looks like a level
two integration.
So the question is, do I need
an SSL certificate to get
notifications from check out?
So this is quite a complex way
to integrate check out.
You need to set up
a web service.
And, to get straight to the
question, the answer is no.
You do not really need to have
a SSL to get notifications
from check out.
Starting with version 2.5 of
the check out API, you can
skip adding the SSL
certificate.
So when you specify your
settings in the Merchant
Center, make sure you select
version 2.5 of the API.
And in the API callback contents
that is sent to you,
make sure you select the radio
button where it says,
notification serial number.
So that does not
require an SSL.
So, that being said, depending
on how you use notifications,
you may not have to set
up a web service at
all with an API callback.
If you do not need them real
time, you can just poll for
notifications.
And we have an API
for that as well.
And then you can get
notifications for specific
time periods, in bulk.
It's up to you.
So there are various ways to
deal with that, and it looks
like you have the knowledge
to implement that service.
PENG YING: And that's what's
happening with version 2.5 of
the API as well, is that
typically you would use an SSL
certificate of your server
to kind of encrypt that
transmission when we're pushing
it to your server,
which is what the XML
notification typically is.
But in 2.5, which we call the
basic API, I think, what's
occurring is that we're sending
you a notification
telling you that you have
a notification.
At which point, you then make
a request to Google, and to
pull that notification.
So you're using Google's SSL
certificate to encrypt that
transaction.
MIHAI IONESCU: So it's
a little bit
more complex handshake.
But it saves you money and
trouble down the road, because
you don't have to add
the SSL certificate.
PENG YING: There's also,
I think, a free
SSL certificate provider.
I believe it's called something
like StartCom.
I forget the name, but there
is a free SSL certificate.
I haven't tried it myself, just
to give you fair notice.
But I have seen it, and I've
tried to download a cert.
Didn't complete it for some
reason, I forgot why.
MIHAI IONESCU: There is
more work involved.
If you can avoid it, if you
don't really need it, then
don't use it.
Use the 2.5 version
of the API.
PENG YING: All right.
I'll take the next question.
When will Wallet offer the
ability to save coupons at
participating merchants?
I could see increased consumer
usage at the point of sale
once coupons and
deals are saved
for NFC enabled merchants.
For example $5 off next
purchase, or of $20 or more.
at Duane Reade.
So last year we actually
launched with a few merchants
of the ability of the tap and
save ability, where you could
tap an NFC sticker and then save
an offer to your Wallet.
And right now, we are
continuously working on
improving that product, because
I think the API--
I think we're trying
to make the API a
little bit more generic.
And I don't know how much detail
I can dive into here.
It's something that we're
definitely working on.
I've done some research about
the space myself.
Something like consumers saved
$4.6 billion dollars by using
coupons in 2011.
I think that's the stat.
And we completely understand.
We understand that there is a
business need for it or a
business want for something
like that.
And we're definitely
working on it.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
So we have a couple
more questions.
So we want to acknowledge that
we receive a lot of questions
about the future roadmap and
new features that we're
working on.
So we cannot really give you
details about those, in
particular NFC availability
and new launches.
But we like that you
asked about them.
And we are definitely going
to forward them to all the
parties involved.
And whenever something new
comes up, you will be the
first to know on this show.
We usually have product
managers, people from the
engineering team, come on the
show and give you details
about new products when we're
ready to launch them.
So it looks like we have one
more question that we can give
you a definite answer on.
And that one is from a merchant
from Australia.
So merchant from Australia is
asking us, if I'm using the
digital goods API can I charge
certain users in US dollars
versus Australian dollars?
And the question is
yes, you can.
And this is a very nice feature,
and one of the nicest
things about the digital
goods API.
You can charge customers in the
currency of their country.
And this is very convenient for
the customer, because it's
a very transparent transaction,
and they will not
incur any currency
conversion fees.
That usually happens when
they're charged
in a different currency.
And on top of that, there may
be extra credit card fees.
So there is a list of available
currencies that you
can find in the respective
documentation, either for the
web API or for the [INAUDIBLE]
billing API.
And all you have to do is change
the currency field in
the JWD of the order and
specify, in this case, US
dollars, USD, instead of AUD.
And the customer will see that,
OK, I'm charged $10, 10
US dollars.
There's a set up of available
currency.
You cannot do this in all
currencies on the planet.
But it's pretty large.
And it covers most countries
where you can expect to have a
good set of paying customers.
And also from your perspective,
it's very nice.
You will not have to worry
at all about currency
conversions.
Even though you're charging in
US dollars, you will be paid
in the currency of your
account, which is AUD,
Australian dollars.
Conversion happens automatically
at the same time
the order is placed.
And money goes straight
into your account.
PENG YING: I think Google syncs
the Forex rate, multiple
times in the day.
I've heard once an hour, but
don't quote me on that one.
So you'll get a pretty accurate
conversion rate as well.
MIHAI IONESCU: So that's
a great way to get more
customers and definitely
increase the revenue.
When they see that they're not
charged extra fees, they're
more willing to pay
the transaction.
All right.
It looks like we're at the
end of our questions.
Thank you, everyone, for sending
questions and sending
us feedback.
We're looking forward to showing
you new products in
the upcoming weeks and answer
any other questions you have.
And if you have feedback about
the Merchant Center, please
send it our way.
PENG YING: We are actually
really excited to show you
some new products.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
PENG YING: Upcoming weeks.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right Well,
see you next time.
Bye bye.
PENG YING: See ya.